An optimization similar to inlining, as far as benefits are concerned,
is called function call inlining. And it takes code that calls a function. So
we do some work. Then we prepare the function parameters. For example, put them
in the right registers, according to the calling convention. Then we call
a function, and then we do more work after that. And when we call a function.
let's say that the function itself was just adding the first two parameters, and
putting that in the return value and then returning. So this sends us back here.
And then we continue with the more work. So this is what a normal function call
looks like. So now we can try to avoid the overheads of calling the function and
returning from it, by doing our work.
Then, we don't have to prepare the function parameters anymore.
Now what we do is we simply take the work of the function and
just plug it in here. So in this case, we add up adding the registers for
example that did contain the values that we eventually ended up parsing here.
So we didn't need to copy these registers to A0 and
A1. And we put the result exactly where we need it, for example, R7,
instead of maybe having to copy from RV to R7.
And then we can continue with our work. So the first benefit of
function call inlining is that it eliminates the calling and
returning overheads, which include not only the function call. Instruction and
the return instructions themselves. But also the code that prepares the function
parameters according to the coding convention. And the code that possibly in
function itself needs to. For example, pull parameters from the stack and
so on. And then possibly also the work here after we return to get
the return value into the register where we need it. All of that can be
done by simply inlining the function and then just using the registers we want.
And just like loop unrolling which helped scheduling do better, so
does function call inlining. Because really what we have is. This is where we
can do scheduling. And then we need to call the function. So these instructions
cannot be moving around beyond this point. We can do scheduling here but again,
we cannot do much of this work before the call. And then the function itself.
Can be scheduled but we have to do it within this. We have three separate
pieces of code, each of which can be scheduled. But we can not for example take
something from here and use it to fill an empty spot here. On the other hand,
after in lining this is just code with no function calls or anything so
now all of this work is schedulable. For example the work from the function can
easily be moved around, assuming that the dependencies allow it.
So inlining also let's us do better scheduling just like loop and rolling did and
for the same reason. Now we have more work that we can play with.
Just like loop and rolling the elimination of the overheads for
calling, returning and so on will reduce the number of instructions.
The better scheduling will let us reduce the CPI. And
that means that we can usually improve the execution time by quite a bit.
The smaller the function, the more benefits from both of these. Because if
the function is very small, the overheads of calling and returning are high,
relative to the work we are actually doing. And also if the function is small,
scheduling within the function is not going to do much, but if we put it.
Into the existing code, suddenly this instruction here can probably be squeezed
into an existing cycle without really adding another cycle. And finally there is
a downside to inlining, and it's very similar to what we had for loop unrolling.